hey what's up guys I'm Kay PhD here
happy apocalypse since it is the 21st
today as I record this and welcome to
the hackintosh pro project so I've done
a couple of projects over the course of
2012 and this will be the first project
that begins around the beginning of 2013
and the purpose of this project or this
series is to create a beast of a video
editing machine for the beginning of
2013 now a lot of people are already
done their own PC builds especially
Windows 8 builds for the beginning of
2013 that's pretty cool in fact we're
giving one away already on this channel
very soon so there's a link to enter to
win that one it's a six hundred dollar
bill but the one that makes this one a
little bit different is objective number
two of this series which is this bill
will be able to dual boot windows and OS
10
why do you might not know but I've been
using a Mac Pro for the past couple of
months basically for my video production
and I've gotten very used to the OS 10
environment so I'm going to continue
using OS 10 now it's using it hoping
that Apple would release you know a new
Mac Pro with an actually very powerful
chip soon but they just slacked on that
so we're taking our own initiative here
and building our own hackintosh now when
you consider an OS 10 machine for video
editing a lot of things come to mind but
you kind of have to rule out the laptops
because they're not really quite as
powerful and aren't really a depth of
video editing at least fluidly anyway I
know the retina MacBook Pros are more
powerful but we're rolling in that also
because the fans are a little loud so
that leaves the Mac Mini which is
basically a glorified laptop so we're
gonna put that aside then you have the
iMac which isn't very upgradable except
for the RAM which you can only max out
once did you wipe that aside as well you
only have the Mac Pro and the hackintosh
hackintosh for those of you who don't
already know is essentially taking your
own parts and putting them all together
and installing OS 10 on it this will
work with a very specific bunch of parts
that work together and you have to do
your research to figure out what parts
work but in future videos in this series
I'll be documenting the selection
process and all that kind of stuff to
making this work with OS 10 and the
newest version of Windows I'm not sure
if I want to do Windows 7 or Windows 8
because I'm so used to Windows 7 but you
guys leave a comment below we'll be able
to pick now the reason I'm going with
the hackintosh besides picking my own
parts and besides taking initiative over
apple is delayed new Mac Pro is price
you might have known already that the
Mac pros are very expensive for what
they start at and an equivalently
specked out hackintosh which is your own
parts might cost half of what the Mac
Pro cost so we'll be documenting like I
said during this video series everything
about this the parts that we use to
build process the install process the
how-to everything about it is going to
be covered in the video series and I
hope you guys are ready for that so this
is just the sort of a pile of video to
introduce you guys to the concept the
rest of the stuff is coming very soon
we're gonna start to pick parts we're
gonna start to build this thing and then
we're gonna roll on with the series and
get to you know benchmark testing gaming
whatever else we do on Windows or OS 10
and actual video editing and we might
see something special at the end of the
series so stay tuned for that and leave
a thumbs up if you're excited or you
like the idea of this series and want to
see it move forward you can also leave
parts suggestions below if you have a
specific set of parts or if you have to
see a certain graphics card in it let me
know and I'll consider it
but more importantly I kind of want to
know if this should do a boot with
Windows 8 and mountain lion or Windows 7
and mountain lion because I haven't even
used Windows 8 on the desktop yet I've
been using it almost entirely on a
laptop so let me know other than that
that's basically it I hope you guys
liked the idea of the project it will be
moving forward soon like I said but not
without your suggestions and your
feedback so again thumbs up and comments
are definitely appreciated and uh yeah
it's almost Christmas and whatever
holidays you celebrate are probably
right around the corner so Happy
Holidays
I'm home for holidays as you can
probably already tell but uh I'll see
you guys in the next video thanks for
watching
Hey
[Music]
you